I've been in business for 14 years.
Acquisition.com, our portfolio, just
over $250 million per year. Nine weeks
ago, just did $106 million in sales
alone, making the Guinness fastest
selling non-fiction book of all time. We
doubled the formal record. And so that
is just my credibility for what I'm
about to share with you, which is 12 of
the most important kind of rules of
thumb that I've learned or picked up
along the way in my business career that
you can use to analyze your business to
know where you are versus where you
could or should be, whether this is a
problem to solve or something that you
just need to manage and pay attention
to. And so this will help you allocate
where you're spending your time within
the business with a clear yes no answer
of am I doing a good job or not. So
let's dive into the first one. The first
one is close rates versus pricing. So if
you sell people stuff, now this is be
specifically for people who sell with a
salesperson in person or a salesman
online, so on the phones or Zoom if
that's how you fancy it. Um I want to
kind of give you kind of a tier ladder
list to think through in terms of rules
of thumb. And so the reason that there's
a relationship between obviously price
and close rate is that if you lower the
price, we know our old supply demand
curves. If you lower price, demand goes
up, etc. Um, the idea is if you're
closing at 80% or more in whatever you
sell, so four out of five people you
talk to buy your thing, you're typically
underpriced by 3 to 4x. That might sound
mindblowing to you, but that is just the
data that I've, again, rule of thumb
that I've collected over many years of
business. Now, underneath of that, let's
say that your closure isn't necessarily
over 80%, but let's say it's 60 to 80.
So you're closing between, you know, uh,
three and four out of five who are
there. You're probably underpriced by
between two and 3x. So if you're
currently charging 100, you might
definitely consider going to 200. And
you might have a 250 or 300 in you, and
you'd be able to make more money. Now,
the next tier above that is between 50
and 60%. So as we get closer, you'll
notice that the uh the jumps compress.
If you're between 50 and 60%, typically
you're underpriced by one and a half to
2x. So that $100 price point should
probably be one and a half. So $150 or
$200. Now if you're between 40 and 50%
close rates, you're probably between
1.25 to 1.5x underpriced. Meaning now
you should be at maybe 125 or consider
150 as a final price point. Now if
you're like, okay, between I'm at 35%.
Well, you're between 30 and 40%. which
for me is appropriately priced under the
assumption you have all of the selling
mechanisms in place to educate a
consumer prior to the purchase so that
you're not creating a pitch or a spiel.
Instead, they've already consumed all of
this stuff prior to the pitch and then
the entire close call is about
personalization and helping them make
the decision. That is appropriately
designed sales motion. If you have that
sales motion and you were closing 35%,
you're appropriately priced. Now,
sometimes people have that close rate,
but they don't have any of that stuff.
And in those conditions, then you still
probably have a double or a triple in
your price if you set a proper sales
motion in place. Now, if you're below
30%. So, that means that less than one
out of three people who you talk to buy,
then you either have an avatar issue,
you're selling to the wrong person, you
have a sales motion issue. Um, and I fix
those two first before ever considering
lowering price because it almost always
is the thing that the sales team might
consider wanting to do if you have a bad
culture on your sales team or an
entrepreneur who's afraid. But more
realistically, raising prices is almost
always the direction that businesses go
in with one clear exception, which is if
you have a business that has unlimited
scale. Let's say you sell a software
product.
Uh that pricing is going to be that
pricing decision is going to be
incredibly important to you because it
balances two of the strongest uh
influencers on the value of your
company, which is going to be if you
lower the price, it will also typically
increase growth. And so uh you've got
your gross margin, which is what the
price dictates. and also the growth as a
result. So if you have these two things
then you lower the price growth rate
goes up. If you raise the price uh gross
margin goes up but growth rate goes
down. And so the idea is we want to
maximize both of those things. Now
that's only for SAS companies which is
probably like 5% of you here. For
everybody else that is kind of my point
here which is that you probably have an
unscalable business which 80% of
businesses are unscalable meaning
they're service- based. And in those
conditions there's only one way you go
in service which is up. Because if you
play it out long enough, you get good.
You get enough demand because you're
good. You can't service everybody. So
you change your chart. You go up. You go
up in price. And then around and around
you go. And the faster you spin that
loop to going up in price,
the more you will progress in business
because your gross margins will go up,
your reputation will go up, you'll be
able to hire better talent because you
can pay them now. And it becomes a
virtuous cycle versus the vicious cycle
of trying to serve more people and
paying less, having lower gross margins,
hiring worse people, having worse
customers at lower prices and around and
ready you go into the toilet. So that is
the end end all beall that is the
pricing ladder that I use between price
and close rate which brings up rule of
thumb number two LTV to CAC. So you'll
notice that a lot of these are
relationships between numbers. And the
reason that's important is um it's not
like oh your price should be this. That
would be ridiculous. Every business is
different, but when we take two
different pieces of the business, we're
t typically paired or anothetical in
nature. Uh so like an example of this
would be like speed and quality. These
are things that are going to be ratios.
So you want to settle as many support
tickets as you can, but you want to make
sure that the support tickets are done
right. If you cleaned buildings, it
would be I want my cleaners to clean as
many places as they can as long as we
still get five star reviews or we still
get we still get retention, we still get
referrals. So it's always going to be
relationships between two things that
are paired which create rules of thumb.
And again these are not written in
stone. These are rules of thumb. So
let's go to the second one. LTV to CAC.
So for those you don't know lifetime
value, how much a customer spends with
you. How much gross profit you make over
the entire lifetime of the customer. CAC
is cost of getting that customer the
door. So in plain speak that's how much
money does it cost you to make more
money. CAC is how much money it cost
you. Lifetime gross profit or lifetime
value is how much you make. Now a very
traditional rule of thumb here in the
software world was 3:1 and this has been
you know pushed all over the internet
and many businesses took that because
all these big tech giants and very you
know huge company CEOs talk about 3 to1
as though it's a rule of law and I want
to say it is true under specific
conditions which only apply to like 5%
of businesses. So let me give you the
other scenarios and what I consider to
be ideal for that. So 3:1 and this
relates to I don't have anything drawn.
Hold on. I'll draw this for you guys. So
this will make more sense. So let's
imagine.
Do we have overhead cam on? Okay.
You guys digging this? All right. So we
have our attraction, right? How we get
people in the door. That's number one.
We have our conversion which is how do
we actually get them to give us money
number two. And then number three we
have our delivery.
So if we were to use a binary scale of
uh zero or one zero or one zero or one
then we would say if we have zero
basically of unlimited scale I put zero
operational drag for attraction
conversion and delivery. What is that?
that's probably a SAS product, right?
You can run ads to a checkout page and
then the SAS the software does the
delivery, right? All the way zeros all
across. And so for that, when you have
all zeros,
3:1 between how much it cost you to to
get a customer and how much you make is
an appropriate uh uh ratio. But what if
one of these three things includes a
human? So, let's give a simple example.
You run ads to a checkout page and then
you have somebody who does delivery. You
have a human being who does delivery.
Well, as soon as that occurs, or said
differently, maybe you run ads to a
salesperson and then you have some sort
of lighter touch delivery on the back
end. In any of these scenarios, I want
to now have six one. Sorry, this is a
one. I want to have six one. Now, why
would I double this? So, let me explain.
As soon as you add a human in the loop,
as soon as you add a human to the
system, you're going to have lumpiness
or inconsistency. So, what do I mean by
that? If, let's use the salesperson
example, you're running ads to a
salesperson. As soon as you get to a
certain point where you've capped that
salesperson's calendar, what do you have
to do? You have to hire another
salesperson. And what happens when you
hire a new salesperson? That person's
not going to be as good as the main
person, especially right off the bat,
and maybe even ever. And so we have to
build into the business padding so that
we can incur the cost of trading
somebody up and also having them suck
because if we're at six to one uh with
our one guy or rather if we were at 3:1
with one guy selling as soon as the next
guy comes in we're below 3 one right and
so we have to be at six to one so that
when that next person comes in we have
some we have some we have some cushion
we got a little cushion for the
cushioning if you will uh that that
gives
Again, padding. I'm keep saying padding,
so you'll probably hear padding a bunch
of times, but that's what it is. Now,
let's say that you've got two of these
three. So, now let's say we're uh we're
running ads and we have a we have a
manual person who's taking the phone
call, closing, and then the delivery is
also service. This is honestly, this is
many of you guys is that you are in
service businesses and this like this is
what it is. Okay, when I'm in this
situation,
I want 9 to1. Now, the reason this is so
difficult for people to wrap their heads
around is that most people want to scale
when their business model has not been
nailed yet. And so, that's why we say
nail it then scale it. And so, people
get ahead of their skis, they
overexpand, they they bring on, you
know, they try to open more locations or
bring on more reps too fast because
their ego is tied to the number rather
than looking at the fundamental
economics of their business and saying,
is this ready to scale? Because if I had
the pick of like I would rather scale
really fast for three years and then
realize the business is broken or spend
three years just nailing all my nailing
the model getting all the metrics right
and then scaling it I would obviously
pick the second one. But the thing is is
people if I say that to you most people
be like well of course I pick the second
one. But people don't behave that way.
And so what you say you would do versus
what you actually do are typically very
different. And so because now I have two
humans in the loop, I'm going to have uh
inefficiencies on delivery when I bring
in a new rep or a new technician or new
whatever who's not going to be as good,
not as not as effective as the other
people. I got to be able to eat that. If
I have a bad uh salesperson when they
come in, I'm going to have to be able to
eat that. And so now I got to be at 9:1
to have the cushion to scale. And then
finally along the same line of thinking,
if I have three people all the way
through, I've got humans who are doing
the attraction, humans who are doing the
conversion, and humans who are doing the
delivery, then I want to be at 12 to1.
All right. Now, I want to put this in
perspective for you guys.
One of the gifts that I could hopefully
give is frame shifts in the change of
perspective. So, [cough]
let me know in the chat. the first year
of gym launch when I started running
ads. Okay, so we had automated here and
I would say we were like probably a.5
here. It has half media um but we had
half kind of like some support reps that
help with tech stuff and then this was
human-based. All right, we had a phone
sales team. What do you think my LTV to
CAC ratio was? Let me know in the chat.
5:1
4:1 6:1 What do you guys think?
Where do you guys wait? Let me see some
nums. Let me see some digits. 6 to1,
4:1, 9 to1, 2:1, 30 to1, Liam. Nice. 30
to1, 3:1, 15 to1. I appreciate the the
belief, guys. Our pit 100 to1, you crazy
mofo. Uh, Ronald 5 to one, 25 to1, 20
to1. Okay, you guys want to know what it
was?
I'll tell you.
The first year of gym launch, my LTV CAC
was 100 to one. I spent a hundred grand
and made 10 million.
Wild
recommend. Uh it was wild, wild times.
Okay. Now, what how is that how is that
possible? Right? How is that possible?
Most of the money that I've made in my
life has happened during these distinct
windows of opportunity where there was
huge arbitrage between what it cost me
to get a customer and what a customer is
worth to me. And uh I've had that happen
four times in my life. And each of those
times have been above 30 to1. And so the
reason I'm so adamant about this is that
I know because I've had it happen that
you have to just keep beating up the
system. You have to keep tweaking the
money model, which is why I made the
book Money Models. You have to keep
cranking on this thing until eventually
you crack through that lever. And so you
see 12 to1 people like that's crazy. I'm
like this is the minimum. And again this
is if you want to scale big you can
absolutely run a business that does six
to1 and you know make a million bucks a
year. Couple million bucks a year. Like
you can do that. I'm saying if you want
to see what the biggest companies in the
world have they have absurd LTV to CAC.
Now what is there's only two ways to
improve that ratio, right? Way one is
you drive CAC down to zero because
there's only two long-term winning
strategies in business. Have extremely
low CAC, which means you build massive
brand A, or B, you have a product that
is viral. Those are the two types of
things that great really big companies
on the cost side. On the other hand, you
have the extremely high LTV side. So
looking for a company, I'll give you an
example of each. So Facebook is a
company that wasn't, oh, we have
unlimited LTV. No, they have a business
where CAC approached zero. And so if you
can get CAC 20 to zero, you could
figuratively get eight billion people
for zero dollars. And when you do that,
even if you make a couple hundred bucks
a year on them, you still make a lot of
money. On the other hand, you might have
a company that's like Salesforce, right?
Uh and a company like that, they might
make a million dollars or $5 million per
year on an enterprise level customer.
Now, that customer isn't coming to them
for free. Now, they do have some brand
of course that's going to offset some of
those CAT costs, but there's still going
to be huge cost of getting those
customers, especially the larger
customers with contracts. They have to
bid against other CRM, etc., etc. And
so, both of those are big companies. The
idea is that you have to know what type
of company you're going and your winning
strategy to scale. And so, to make this
extraordinary LTV to CAC ratios, one of
these has to approach zero or infinity.
That's the game. So, that's the second
rule of thumb. Look at your three steps.
Am I zero to one on attraction? Do I
have unlimited scale on attraction? So
if if you're like, what's an unscalable
version? This would be like I do manual
outreach. That would be human in the
loop versus I run ads or I make content.
Conversion here would be checkout page
is scalable. Human uh phone team or
sales team in person that has a human.
Delivery. If I sell services, I'm going
to have humans. If I sell software, I
sell media that's going to not have
humans. I sell physical products for
example, that would still not have
humans by my definition. That's the
idea. You can see what your LTV
character ratios are. You can see where
you're at and whether you need to
improve them. Which brings me to rule
numero t. That is uh Spanish for rule
number three. I think it be. But like
let's not get crazy. Um no gift.
I messed that one up. Either way,
hopefully you're with me. Real quick, I
have a gift for you. This is the $100
million scaling road map. It's something
that my team and I put 200 plus hours
into building and breaking the stages of
scaling into 10 steps. All right? All
right. And so what we did is we broke
down everything that got us basically
got us stuck and what we did to break
free at each level of the business. And
if you'd like to know what product,
marketing, sales, customer service, IT,
recruiting, human uh resources, and
finance look like at the stage that
you're currently at, this is a free
gift. So all you have to do is go to
aquis.com/romap. You can plug in your
business information. And if you want
our help, you want my help to help you
break through whatever level of scaling
you're at. This is not a promise. I'm
just saying we'd love to help. Um on the
thank you page, you can book a call. Uh,
every month we have a workshop out here
at my headquarters. You actually talk to
my real team that does does our
marketing, does our emails, does our
ads, does our copy, does our does our
does our sales, does our finance, does
our recruiting, the real people are
doing this at a very high level. And
what's really cool about that is that
they can typically find and spot what
the constraints are in a business like
that. And so it's one of the most
valuable things that I could possibly
do. Obviously, you know, space is
limited based on our actual
headquarters. Um, but if that's
interesting on the thank you page, you
can book a call. No pressure. This is a
gift either way. It's absolutely free.
So rule number three is rule of 100. So
fundamentally, if you're trying to grow
the business, I have never seen a
business not grow when they implement
the rule of 100 when they're starting
out. And to be clear, this works for all
levels. So it's either rule of 100 on
your first acquisition channel or rule
of 100 and ideally for 100 days. So 100
and 100, right? And if you're like,
wait, 100 times 100, you're like, you're
right. That's 10,000 actions. And what
happens when you take 10,000 actions in
one specific direction, you tend to get
results. And the amount of like
screenshots of like uh content and reach
and impressions that I've got from
people who actually tick the box 100
days in a row doing 100 actions that
they get their first customer. Most
people get it by like the third week.
But you have to commit to doing 100
days. And it's kind of like the very the
the the idea of like the heart of a
missionary versus a mercenary. You have
to commit in your heart that you're
going to do 100 days. And then it
happens very quickly. If you try to do
this for 100 days to try and prove me
wrong, congratulations.
You won. You're still not succeeding.
Probably not the perspective because it
won't change anything in my life. All
right? And so where this uh becomes a
symptom that you can recognize in your
business is volatility. All right? And I
said this applies to all levels. So if
you're a bigger business owner, you take
the rule of 100 and you just apply it to
new channels. And so if you're like, we
run meta ads, it's like great. Well, we
needed to take the same perspective on
how we're going to run YouTube ads or
Google ads, right? If you're on content
side, it's like we make, you know,
reels. Uh, awesome. It's like, okay, we
do it on this platform. We need to do
this on a second platform. If you're
doing outreach, you every time you
expand into the new platform or medium
or channel, you would implement the rule
100 yet again. Now, if you're a smaller
business, which most businesses are
small by statistics and reality,
95% of business left in a million
dollars. So here we go. If your business
feels feast or famine, meaning if you
get a sale this week and then there's
nothing and there's nothing and then
next week you get one and then two more
weeks and then one two and then another
three weeks of famine. The issue is not
that you have quote inconsistent
lead flow. It feels inconsistent because
the timeline you're measuring it on is
too small. So, if I were to look at it
year-over-year, if you're the type of
business that does a small amount of
advertising, you might sell about the
same amount of number of customers every
single year, but that volatility or the
perception of volatility is a symptom of
insufficient volume. You're not doing
enough to get enough out. Now, if we
expand that time horizon, let's say that
we expand it to 30 days and let's say
that you on average get third three
customers a month. Okay, 30 days, three
customers a month. That means you get
one customer per 10 days. And so that
means that in 10 days what we can
reverse this into is that there is an
amount of advertising that is occurring
either through content through word of
mouth through uh outreach through paid
ads whatever affiliates people referring
to you who are partners or you know
centers of influence if you will or
we're sending you business that in that
10 days there's enough advertising for
one sale to occur. And so the idea is,
okay, well, if I can just look at the
amount of advertising that I'm doing
probably haphazardly over a 10-day
period and then do it deliberately
instead of on accident on a daily basis,
then I could take what I do in
advertising in 10 days and do it in one.
And if I do it in one, then I'm going to
get the same outcome as doing one sale
every 10 and I'll get one sale every
day. And so the companies that are doing
30 times more sales than you are
typically doing 30 times more
advertising than you are. real. And so
I've put this in perspective many I've
seen I mean because obviously businesses
fly out here every every week.com so I
know a lot of numbers around what
businesses are doing at different
revenue levels. If I look at a one or
two million dollar business and I look
at how much content they're putting out
just on a pure volume basis and the
thing is is like of course there's
quality of content but the thing is is
if if you look at it across all pieces
of content with the outliers already
baked in that you know that one out of
10 or one out of 100 are going to be
super outliers of course the top 1% the
top one out of 100 the top 10% you know
one out of 10. Um with that volume baked
in things tend to normalize again. And
so we make whatever it is 450 pieces of
content a week, right? Almost 500 for
simple math. So we're looking at third,
you know, 25 30,000 pieces of content
per year. And many of the people that
are at $1 million are doing something in
the neighborhood of like one a day. And
so they're doing 365 and we're doing
like 25 or 30,000. And so we get nine or
10 times the uh sorry uh uh way way more
than that. Sorry, that's a thousand
times uh thousand times the outcome that
they are. Now, you could even make the
argument that I'm even less efficient
than they are, but diminishing returns
are still returns, right? So, like if I
do a thousand times more than you, but I
get a hundred times the outcome, I'm
good with that. And I think this is the
piece that people really mess up is they
see diminishing returns and then think,
"Oh, I should stop because my return per
action has gone down." Rather than
thinking, "I'm still getting more and
it's still worth it." And that's the
part that I think most people who are
smaller miss out on. the amount of
conversations I've had with small
business owners who are all about
optimization. Again, there's nothing
wrong with that. You just can't have
both. You can be like, I want to
optimize. It's like fine, you can get
the most for the least, but you're not
going to get the most. Period. And the
difference is that the people who want
the most are the ones who win.
Which leads me to rule number four, lead
response times. So, rule of thumb here,
for the love of God, please call your
leads within 60 seconds. I don't know
how how many times I have to say this
across how many videos and it's just
like do you hate helping people? Do you
hate having more revenue and more profit
in the business? Would you prefer to pay
four times more per customer than you
currently are because you are like, you
know what we're going to do? So this
person just opted in. They're like, you
know what? I really want to solve this
problem. This company looks interesting.
And then you're on the other side
saying, let's let them cool off a little
bit. they're a little they're a little
too he hot and heavy, you know what I
mean? Like, let's make sure they don't
make a decision that they would regret.
You know, I don't want them to take that
wallet out too fast because that might
be unreasonable. And so, let's let them
simmer. Let's let them marinate for a
couple days. And you know what? Let's
let them date around. Let's let them
call some other businesses so that by
the time we finally get to them, if we
ever do get to them, they have a lot
more information from different
competitors so they can compare the pros
and cons of our business and our
offering to everyone else so that we can
get in a pricing war all the way to the
bottom. And so when we do that, not only
are we spending four times as much as we
should to acquire a customer, we're also
not able to make as much per customer
because your close rates will go down on
top of that and so will your gross
margins. And so it's one of those like I
think Brian Johnson from Blueprint was
talking about this. You're like where is
he going with this? I'll bring it back
home. He said he has boiled down like
however many years of doing all this
research and stuff into one number which
is your resting heart rate before bed.
He said if you show me that number I can
see your soul. To me I would say LTV to
CAC would be that number but [laughter]
underneath of that number would be would
be your lead response time. And the
reason for that is like it's how you do
one thing is how you do everything. And
I have some elements that I take take uh
offense to that particular term. But I
do think that it is a way of doing
business. How dedicated to excellence
are you? Right? And if you know if you
know this has been proven over and over
again in business studies and in the
real world, right? Saying, "Hey, you're
going to 4x your sales." People think,
"Yeah, but I can't I can't afford to
hire somebody to call my leads in that
speed." Well, do you think if you had
four times the revenue you currently do
that you'd be able to afford it with the
revenue that you would now make from
that person? This is how business works.
You invest and then you get something
back. That's how it works. But this is
the first time I think I framed it the
other way around. Look at how much it
cost you to get a customer. If you
divided that by four, would that improve
your LTV to CAC ratio?
Would that be the thing that you need in
order to scale? Do you think that it
your leads cost too much might be a
factor of the fact that you don't know
how to sell?
So when I look at rules of thumb, it's
like, well, I'm going to attack these
areas first because there's huge returns
for minimal effort. Talk about, you
know, maximizing, optimizing. For the
love of God, please call your leads
quickly. [sighs]
Sorry, a little passionate about that
one. All right. Think the spirit moves?
I'm sorry.
I don't take it back. We can just move
on. Okay, which brings me to rule number
five. 70% calendar utilization. Okay, so
this is a rule of thumb. So when you
have more salespeople,
there's another issue that starts to
come up, which is my sales team's
underutilized or they're booked out. So
what's the sweet spot? The reason this
is important is because well, if you
miss it, you will let me let me go
either extreme. If you have your sales
team completely booked out, fully
utilized, here's two things that happen
as a result that are bad. Number one is
that your total lead conversion will go
down. You will make more sales because
they're booked out for sure. Absolute
will go up, but your your conversion
rates will go down, meaning your CAC,
your cost to acquire customers will go
up. Um, which is depending on how
sensitive your numbers are, could be
very bad for the business. And so that
utilization happens. And as a result,
one, people have to start booking out
further and further because tomorrow,
the next day, they're all booked out.
They can't find convenient times. So,
one, it's further out. And so, show
rates on further out appointments
compared to sooner appointments goes
down. Number two, show rate on
appointments that are inconvenient
versus convenient. Maybe they do it a
little bit sooner, but it's still not
the time they'd ideally like. Show rates
go down. Number three, what happens if a
sales guy is making calls all day long?
What are they not doing? They're not
doing outbound. What are they also not
doing? They're not following up on the
the calls that they should just they
have six-inch putts. They have some
tipins that they need to do that they
just aren't doing because they're on
calls today. And rightfully so. They
should be focused on like they should
reasonably focus on the leads that are
in front of them. But it is your job as
the entrepreneur to move their calendar
better utilize their time so you can
maximize conversion. Okay. So on the
other extreme, let's say that you have
30% utilization. uh so you know 70% of
their calendars uh empty. The problem
with this that I found is that sales
team morale can start to drop because
they're they don't really ever get in
momentum. So if you have like two calls
a day, like the calls sometimes mean too
much. And so guys have kind of
commission breath. They're like, I have
to close the sale, right? I'm not going
to get paid. And so it's a balance
between both those things. So I've found
70% is kind of the sweet spot. I don't
let it get above 85. Um and I try not to
let it drop below 60. And so that's kind
of give you a range. I would say 707 75
is right around the sweet spot for this.
And I'll and I'll explain the reasoning
why. When we see conversion rates, as in
if we get 100 leads, we want to maximize
the conversion of those leads, which
function functionally is what a sales
team's supposed to do. Why why you have
sales team rather than just a checkout
page. If we want to maximize that
conversion,
then we want to give the time we want to
give one enough times for the prospect
to book soon. Two, enough times for that
time to be convenient for them. Both of
these things increase show rates. Number
three, we want to have the salesperson
have enough blank space in their
calendar so they can work their pipeline
and bring people back in. And I remember
the realization I had around this was we
would have high weeks and low weeks with
ads in terms of book calendars, but our
sales remained relatively the same. And
I was like, how does that work? And it
was just because when a big wave came
in, the guys were really inefficient.
And when there was, you know, a famine,
if you will, and there was more empty
calendars, the guys squeezed their
pipelines. And so I was like, man, if we
just squeezed our pipelines all the
time, we would just make on the high
weeks, we'd make so much more money.
Well, how do you do that? You typically
need to hire more sales people. And I
will say as a as a personal note, I have
yet to make less money by hiring more
sales.
So like when in doubt, sales tends to
drive business. And I also have some
belief around the fact, and this is most
cultures, not ours here at Acquisition,
but the vast majority of sales cultures,
guys will get fat and happy. they will
make enough sales to make whatever that
nut is for them that they don't want to
work that hard anymore. And so I would
rather have the guys just below whatever
that that that amount is. So they're
always striving. They're always
squeezing the pipeline rather than you
know they can sell to their goal within
the first two weeks and then they take
the last two weeks of the month off. And
that's where um you know entrepreneurs,
hey do I need to change my sales
commissions? Maybe. But more often than
not, it's like you can just add sales
people so that they can squeeze their
opportunities better. All right, which
leads me to rule number six. Payback
period. Actually, that sound felt very
aggressive. Payback. Um, so what is
payback period? It's how quickly you can
recover the cost of getting a customer.
Now, for me, ideally, I try to do within
30 days. So, payback period in general
is how fast you get the money back from
what it cost you to get somebody. My
goal is within 30 days. Why? Because
just about every business owner, at
least in America and at least the
developed world, can typically gain
access to a credit card which gives you
30 days of interest free money. Now, the
reason that's important is that if you
have interest free money, that it means
that you can grow without money out of
pocket. And that allows you to have
limitless growth. If it if I can take a
$100 of credit card money, which I don't
have to pay anything for until the end
of the month, and I can take that $100
and go get me a customer, and at the end
of the month, make that $100 back, then
at the end of the month, I owe no one
anything, and I now have a customer.
That is the power of this. Now you can
repeat that at infin item which is Latin
for lots of times. It's into infinity
but let's not get let's not get too
technical. Um so the reason that I use
that as my as my as my rule of thumb is
for that very practical reason. Now you
might think to yourself well our payback
period is 90 days. There's nothing wrong
with that. It's the same as like you
know we had LTV to CAC at gym launch of
100 to1. It didn't stay 100 to1. It was
1001 the first year right and over time
it ended up being somewhere in the area
of 30-ish to1. Um but the idea because
as you scale more levels of of
infrastructure will get introduced to
the business and so that will drive down
operating margins and that's okay as
long as you have a business that scales.
Now back to payback period.
You can I want to shift the perspective
on this which is that like even if you
currently spend and get paid back in 90,
you should still think to yourself like
is there a way is there a money model?
Is there a setup? Is there a
configuration of pricing and products of
what I currently have without
introducing operational drag or too much
operational drag that could pull cash
forward? And functionally, this is
literally what the entire book for money
models was about was driving more cash
flow forward. Now, if you have a
business where you're funded from the
outside, A or B, you're very large
business that has huge capital reserves,
you have a huge base of recurring
customers, then you can get more
aggressive, of course, right? Like if if
you're going to go head-to-head with,
you know, Apple, then sure, they can
they don't need to get their money back
in 30 days. I mean, they are a bank at
this point. Like, they can they can
borrow money from the entire world and
and fund whatever they want. Um, but for
again everybody who's watching this,
most of you guys are bootstrapped.
Actually, can we do a poll real quick?
All right, let's say who here is
bootstrapped versus has investors.
That's it. Bootstrap versus investors.
Okay, great. So, one out of 25 of you
guys, you don't have to worry about the
payback period, but you still should.
Uh, which is all the investor bros. Now,
all the guys who have in outside
investors, I promise you, you will get
investors frothing at the mouth if you
can uh show that you can get payback
period within 30 days. Number one.
Number two,
if you have payback within 30 days,
guess what? You also don't need
investors because you don't need their
money to scale, which gives you a huge
amount of leverage into when you're
getting into your fundraising period.
Now, that's the one out of 25. For the
other 20 out of 25 of you who are
bootstrap business owners, y'all are
like me, which is that I like Bank of
Alex is what's funding this stuff. And
so, we have to think, are there
initiation fees? Are there setup fees?
Are there is there an onboarding
process? Is there an on-ramp? Is there a
front-end defined program or setup that
I can sell? Can I can I bundle in some
sort of physical product upfront with my
services? Can I sell a bundle of an
extended period of time to cash flow at
day one? Can I do a buy one get two? Can
I get them to pay for the last month up
front? All of these are different
tactical versions of solving for the
same problem, which is I want to pull
cash forward so I can recover CAC within
that first month. Because when that
happens, I'm telling you, like all of my
businesses, every single one that's
gotten really big, we have been able to
recover what it cost us to get a
customer in the in the first 30 days.
Period.
So, it's the strongest recommendation I
can give you. All right, with that being
said, let's go. Rule number that's a
six. There you go. Rule number seven,
gross margins. So, gross margins are
wildly misunderstood, which is
interesting. Um,
if you are if you are a business owner,
you you have to learn the language of
business. All right? It is it is for
sure. There there are different
languages, but there's there's not a
huge amount of words that you have to
know. You might need to know like a
hundred terms. And think about this is
like you were studying for a test,
right? Like learning a 100 terms not
that hard to understand. And almost all
of them are relationships between two
things. That's what almost all of these
terms are. So what is gross margin? It's
one word that's a relationship between
two things. How much you charge and how
much it cost you to deliver the thing.
And the difference between those things
is your gross margin. To be clear,
that's not your net profit margin, which
is a different ratio, right? Between
two, not necessarily ratio, but the
difference between two different
numbers, right? But your gross margins
are very important because it is what
dictates everything else in the
business. So what do I mean by that? If
you like your net margins cannot exceed
your gross margins. Think about that for
a moment. If you have if you're like,
"Man, I'd love to run a 50% net margin
business." That's an amazing goal and I
love that goal for you. If your gross
margins are 50%, that means that you can
have literally no other cost besides the
thing you sell in the entire business.
You can't have any cost of acquiring
customers. You can't have any fixed
overhead. You can't have any employees
that are not specifically in delivery.
You can't have any admin, any help, of
course. Now, the likelihood of of you
getting to a 50% margin when you have
50% gross margins is basically zero. And
so this is why and and traditionally
small business owners will undercharge
because they sell out of their own
wallet, right? And they sell out of
their own wallet in two different ways.
They sell out of their own wallet
because they don't have that much money
and so they feel bad charging other
people when they don't have much money
because they're like, "Man, I get what
it's like to struggle." And I think
there's nothing wrong with that. It's
just understand the business is not
going to grow. You're not going to hire
more people. The other reason they sell
out of their own wallet is that they
believe that the service they deliver is
not that valuable because they know how
to do it. So to quote the joker, right,
my father always told me when you're
good at something, never do it for free,
right? And so the idea is that like you
I like if you're good at fixing cars,
right, you're like well it comes
naturally. It's not that hard. You got
to know where the you know it's like
it's what we do is really
straightforward to you. to you, but to a
customer, we have to sell off the value
of what their life would be like if they
didn't have this problem solved. That is
what we have to charge off of. And when
we charge off of those prices, then we
create more opportunity for gross
margin. Now, here's why this is so
important. Let me give you a math
example that will blow your minds. And I
always, you know, everyone everyone gets
harpotations when I say math. So, let's
just say a money example. Okay? So,
let's give you a money example that'll
get you really happy. All right? So,
let's say that I've got some service
that I that I deliver, okay? And it
costs me a 100 bucks a month, okay?
That's what it costs me in services and
whatever. All right? So, if I want to
have
80% gross margins, which I said these
are rules of thumb. My rule of thumb for
services is at least 80. Okay? So, I
want to show you two different scenarios
here. So, at 80%
at 80% this $100 I have to have $500 has
to be my price. Okay, at 70%
and I have a $100 cost.
Who's who can do this math for me? All
right, I got to do this. All right, 100
equals.7.
Julian, you were premed. Do it for me.
or I'll tell you what [laughter]
I'll tell you what 90% looks like
equals $1,000. [laughter]
All right, where is it? Where where we
at? Why you jackasses keep asking alive?
Thank you, G Salons.
Is it 350? Is that it? We should We
should know this. I feel like as a
collective community we should be able
to figure out when uh 30% okay so it
should be 100 divided by.3 is what it
should be so 100 divided by.3 right
is 330 thank you so that would mean that
233 should be 70%. Um,
so 233 divided by 333,
correct? Thank you. Okay, so 333.
Okay, so look at how big of a difference
this is, right? Between these between
these numbers, look at how like when
people are like, "Oh, well my my margins
are at 60%, so I'm close to 80." It's
like, bro, we're not even like you're in
a different stratosphere. Okay, so let's
take this to the natural end.
If you have a business, let's say that
runs 20% margins at net margins at the
end of the year, what you can pay
yourself, right? If we say, "Hey, is
there a way you think we could go from
70% to 90%." Well, that that sounds like
it's not that big of a deal. But when
you go from 70 to 90, what happens to
the actual margin?
You double. You make way more money. And
sometimes it means a lot more than that
because sometimes the incremental margin
is all margin whereas every dollar
revenue up to that point covered cost,
right? And so what is our
we make $233 here, right? We make $400
here and we make $900 here per customer.
Big difference, right? And so when
people hear these numbers, because these
numbers look similar, they think that
these are going to be very similar and
they are not.
And so this is why I'm so adamant that
80% is my minimum. I target like that's
my baseline. And then from like I will
not get into a business with less than
80% gross margins. I won't do it because
I know that I then have to run
everything else off of this 80. Right?
So if I want to have a 50% net margin
business, I only have 30% left. I got
30% to cover everything else. I got to
cover rent. I got to cover admin. I got
to cover insurance. I got to cover um I
got to cover uh marketing. I got to
cover sales. I got to cover everything
else with just this 30% so I can have
50% left over.
Is this is this ringing? Is this ringing
with you guys? Is this making sense?
Even if it's a service based business,
bro, this is for service- based
businesses, not DN Australia. This is
for service- based businesses.
And this may this is why like
so ideally I like to have I mean again
this is minimum and I know this is going
to blow your minds here like I like one
of the first things we did when we fixed
gyms is we made sure the pricing was at
least 80% gross margins.
That's a service business. Now some of
you are like well there that's not
possible. Of course it's possible. It's
not possible when you sell a commodity.
If a customer can look at your thing and
somebody down the street's thing and
say, "These are about the same. I'll buy
the cheaper one." You sell a
commoditized service just like you can
sell a commoditized product. And so you
might have salt and salt and you got FSG
salt and whatever, you know, pink
Himalayan, it's salt, right? And so how
do we make these two things different?
We have to brand it's pink Himalayan
versus just normal salt, right? And they
charge a premium for that. And so you
have to figure out how to reconfigure.
If only there were a book written about
how to make an offer that's
decommoditized so that you could achieve
80% or higher gross margins, that would
be amazing, wouldn't it? And for those
of you who don't know, I wrote a book on
this. It's called $100 million offers.
27,000 five star reviews. You should
read it. But I I want to draw this
because this like if you're trying to
figure out what's wrong with your
business, it's usually because your
margins are off. You're mispriced. But
again, sometimes this is this is the
this is the fundamental mathematical
problem with the business. But this
might really be the symptom of the fact
that you have a commoditized offer. A B
you have a sales process that doesn't
function properly, right? Um, and so
that's the that's the big idea. So if
you want to run a high margin business,
then you have to run exceptionally high
gross margins for whatever it is that
you sell. Okay, cool. That math was
tough, wasn't it? All right, so let's do
rule number eight. Rule of thumb number
eight, if you will. Uh, 30-day cash
collected. So, this is a this is an
add-on to the the the 30-day payback
period. So,
what is the exact amount of money that I
want to have collected within that 30
days? It's going to be COG. So, the cost
of delivering cost of goods sold. I'll
just write out cost of goods
sold. Now, the goods sold can be
services too to be clear. So it's cost
of goods sold, how much it cost you for
the stuff plus cost of getting
customer.
Okay, so if we have the cost of getting
the customer and the cost of whatever we
got them back, we want both those things
together.
We want whatever we collect to be
greater
We want the gross profit or the cash we
collect in that first 30 days to be
greater than this plus this.
The reason this is so magical is that
once this occurs,
customer comes in, you acquire that
customer and then you have to deliver on
that customer. And then that customer
pays you back all of that cost and then
what can you do?
Go get you another customer.
That is why it's so magical. And so that
is what the whole point of this 30-day
cash collected thing is. We want to pull
it forward.
Cool.
Great. Now, manufacturing study with
Zoro. No. Manufacturing, you're going to
have different margins because you have
cost of goods sold and that's going to
be a little different. Um I would to be
fair, I would still prefer to have a
business that has 80% gross margins. But
with services, for human services, um I
I have that as my rule of thumb is that
I always want 80% or higher gross
margins. Okay.
That brings us to rule number 10, which
is functionally rule number nine, but
we're calling it 10 because I skipped
number nine. Let's just go with which is
turn and retention. So,
I want to only have to acquire customers
once. The reason that most businesses
cannot get big is because they are
always filling a leaky bucket. Now,
you've heard this terminology before,
but think about how difficult it is to
acquire a customer. It's a lot of work,
right? And to go through that entire
process only to lose them to have to go
get another one is exhausting. And so
you want to be and this is John Paul
Deorio uh is the quote from him. He said
you don't want to be in the sales
business you want to be in the reselling
business. And so what he meant by that
is how do we get customers to just buy
again and again and again which does
come down to product primarily and then
brand secondarily. And so the idea here
is that for your business to be a
significantly more valuable but b way
more fun to run you want to keep the
customers you have. And so when you're a
small business owner, you're typically
just barely figuring out what's going
on. And so what happens is people will
typically try to scale too fast before
they've actually figured out revenue
retention and churn. And so what are
quote good benchmarks? Well, good
benchmarks for anything B2B is you
probably want to be above 80%.
In terms of retention annually that
means that if I get a 100 customers gen
1, right? So, this is January 1.
Let's say 2025,
Jan 1, uh, 2026. I want to make sure
that I have at least 80 of these
customers. Now, this is where people get
confused. Let's say that they grow
because they get better at marketing
sales throughout the year. They and they
come January 26 and let's say they're at
160 customers is how many they have.
They think, "Oh, well, I definitely
retained all 100 customers and I also
got 60 more." Uh-uh. We're looking at of
the original 100, how many of them made
it to here. This is the issue. Now, you
can take whatever your annual retention
is and then you can basically reverse
engineer into what your lifetime uh
value of a customer is. So, if you have
50% annual retention, then you can take
whatever someone pays over a year, let's
use simple math and say someone pays
$100 per year. If you have 50% annual
retention, then it means that you can
basically double it. So, you divide it
by 50%.
equals $200 is what you're going to make
from a customer. Now, here's where this
gets really wild. Let's say that you
have 80% annual retention. Doesn't seem
like that much different, right? It's
only 30%. What is it actually different
from a math perspective? It means that
you're going to get functionally
four turns, five turns, five turns
because every year you're going to lose
20%. Right? And so, simple math on that
is around the back of napkin on that is
about $500.
what
a lot.
All right. And so think about two
businesses and this is why this is so
important.
The cost of getting customers between
different businesses is typically very
uh commoditized. So CAC in an industry
is a commodity. Think about how weird
that is as as a sentence. If there's two
social media marketing agencies that
both sell generically similar services,
now of course we don't want to do that.
But this is how the the industry by and
large works. If you have two different
businesses that are selling the rel
relative to the same thing, the cost of
getting customers there is typically
about the same. Here is where one
business can become 5, 10, 100 times
more valuable is that those customers
are worth five, 10, 100 times more to
the other business. And so they are able
to to play a huge arbitrage game. So
they can spend way more money in the
acquisition than the than the the
business that only has call it 50%
retention. Right? This guy's getting two
and a half times more per customer than
the first company. Even though maybe the
cost of getting the customer in both
these scenarios might be the same. This
is where there's huge amount of alpha or
kind of arbitrage above what market
could get um in terms of improving a
business. And so right now if you don't
know how many customers stay with you
year-over-year, definitely worth
figuring out. And so that is my rule of
thumb is that I target. And so for each
of these numbers as I'm sharing them is
like this is my target. This is what I
want to get to. And if I don't have
that, I see this as a huge problem in
the business and I have to go fix it.
Otherwise, I just know that I'm going to
create a I'm going to scale problems.
Right? When you scale problems, they
just get meaner and uglier and they have
more faces on them. Right? You do not
want to do that. And this is where most
people's ego gets tight dominated, which
is why most entrepreneurs can't scale.
All right. So rule number 11. What is a
good rule of thumb for how many people
prepay? So, a lot of you guys uh some of
you guys follow my stuff. Um I'm
obviously a big fan of pulling cash
forward because of all the reasons I
already mentioned. One is if someone
prepays for a year, no one can churn if
you prepay, right? You already pay for
the year. Can't really turn out, right?
Uh what other benefits uh happen when
when you prepay? Well, if you uh prepay,
you get all that cash today. If you get
all that cash today, what can you use do
with that cash? Go get more customers,
right? Think about this.
Everybody here should at least give a
10% discount for getting paid in full
today. Why? Because the value of money
today is typically at least or at least
that same value of that money in a year
will be worth 10% more at minimum. You
could take the money, put it in the darn
stock market, right? And then wait a
year and it would be worth 10% more. All
right? [laughter] And so like at
[clears throat] minimum that is a that
is the amount that I'm willing to give
to pull cash forward. All right? Now,
what percentages rule of thumb uh should
you expect? So, let me give you a
couple. So, um if you have uh call it a
a uh like a buy 10 get two type deal,
like you pay for 10 months and you get
uh you get two for free, you can expect
somewhere in the neighborhood of like 15
to 20% of people to take that offer. All
right? if you give uh discounts in
excess of that and and you give bonuses
for people prepaying. And so the way I
think about that is three ways you can
do that. How can I how can I deliver
something to them faster? How can I make
it less risky? Uh and then how can I
make it easier? So if I say, "Hey, um
you can prepay and if you prepay, you
skip the line." Ah, that sounds nice.
Hey, if you prepay, you'll get a
dedicated concierge versus being in
group. Hey, if you uh prepay, I'll also
add in our guarantee or I'll double the
length of our guarantee. Right? So,
these are some of the things that you
can manipulate in terms of variables to
pull cash forward. Now, when you have a
a moderate discount plus one of one or
more of those kind of like um ancillary
benefits that I just rattled off, you
should expect 30 to 40% of people to
prepay. That's a monster difference in
terms of cash forward. Now, simply
offering that for many of you, if you're
not doing it, we'll pull cash forward.
Now, a correlary to that is whether you
have a third party financing company.
Now, this is directly from um a firm. Uh
so, I know a lot of the high-ups at a
firm, not a lot, I just know a very high
up at a firm, I'll just say that. U a
handful of them. Uh and the the metrics
that they quote is a 35% increase in
sales overall. Kind of interesting. So,
not only does that money come forward,
if you have good financing, you can also
increase sales overall. People who would
not have been able to buy are now
willing to because they have more
convenient ways of paying. So, that kind
of gives you a double whammy of, oh,
people who wouldn't buy did. And they
went from not buying to me having all
that cash today, which is why having
very good financing partners can be a
huge game changer for a business. Now, I
will I'll put this little caveat in
place, which is that financing will not
save your business. If your if your food
sucks at your restaurant, financing it
will just get more people to find out
that the food sucks faster. All right,
so I've never seen a business get saved
by this. But I have seen businesses grow
for sure by making some of these deals
and putting them in place. Now, let me
give you a couple payment structures
that you can use um that have worked
really well for me. So, right off the
bat, if you just say like, "Hey, people
go into monthly." It's like, "That's a
way of doing things." But I would prefer
to sell durations and then say, "Cool,
prepay and get guarantee, priority, and
concierge, right? Let's pull it
forward." If they still can, I say,
"Great. Let's split it. Half now, half
in a month." Now, this is little little
pro tip on this. Half now, half in a
month. I might sell 3 months or 6 months
of stuff. There's no need for me to wait
3 to 6 months to get paid. I still want
to get paid now and in 30 days cuz they
got the money. I might as well ask,
right? The worst they can say is no.
After they say no to two, I say great,
let's go for a third payment. Again,
one, two, three. Even if it's a
six-month or 12-month, I want to pull
that cash forward. Now, a little pro tip
again is always ask if it's to uh if
you're if you're talking to a wage, uh
[gasps] ask them when they get paid and
then align the payments on those days.
If you're not talking to a wugee, you
can ask when they have the prim uh the
majority of their deposits hit, when
they are the most cash flush cash flush
in the business, and then you can set it
for those dates. Um, you do not need to
coordinate payments with your delivery.
Now, one of my favorite uh methods of
payment so that I can pull cash forward
is something that came out of the
depression in the 1930s, which is
something called Leo. It might be
something as old as time. I'm sure it
was in 2000 BC, but I just know from the
from the depression because of course I
lived there um at that time. And so the
way it works is simple. You start paying
now and when you finish paying, you get
the thing. Very straightforward. That's
it. So you can I remember and I remember
the first time I did this um I had I was
selling this is with Allen. I was
selling uh we had this big onboarding
because what Allen was hire kind of
enterprise SAS. So, we would sell to
agencies. Uh, it was $25,000 to white
label and then they would use it kind of
as their own operating system. And so,
it cost 25 grand to kind of like get
onboarded. And so, I would do two two
agencies at a time. We do a full day
onboarding with me and my team and we'd
help them get set up, walk them through
everything, etc. Right now, I remember
having uh uh two partners who were on
the phone uh saying uh they're like 25
grand. They're like, "That's awesome."
Um, and then uh they said, "Can we split
into payments?" And I said, "Sure." And
they said, "Well, um, how many payments
can I split it up to?" And I said, "As
many as you want." And they were like,
"Oh, amazing. We'll just spend, you
know, we'll just do 2,000 bucks a month,
um, and we'll we'll pay it off, you
know, this year." And I said, "Okay,
cool. So, we'll just set your onboarding
for a year from now." And they were
like, "Oh, we got to like pay before we
come in." And I was like, "Yeah." And
they, it was, this was why it was such a
reinforcing moment for me. They just
said, "Oh, okay. Okay. Well, we'll do
half now and half in a month and we'll
be out next month. And so, what's cool
about layaway is that when people
understand that like the faster they
pay, the faster they get, they are now
incentivized to pay it off as fast as
possible rather than you trying to pull
it forward, which is why I'm such a big
fan of layaway as a payment option. In
addition to that, collections become
significantly easier because they
haven't got anything yet and so they've
already decided they want this thing. I
also like layaway because people have
anticipation. Think about the last
thing. Maybe you were a kid when you did
this, but like I remember there was this
pair of Oakley sunglasses that I thought
were the coolest ones. You might have
remembered them. They were in um X-Men.
Cyclops had that like orange that orange
pair. I think I was like I don't know
young when that came out. And I thought
he looked like the coolest guy ever. So
I saved up for a whole summer doing
chores to buy $160 sunglasses, right?
Which is absurd. But I I I think they
were $120 or $160 at the time,
inflation. Um, and they were like the
hottest, coolest sunglasses. So anyways,
I save up the money. I get the
sunglasses. And I remember the
anticipation of being able to get the
sunglasses at the end of the summer was
better than the sunglasses ever were. In
fact, it was so good. I literally never
wore them because I was so afraid of
losing them because I spent so long to
save them. Um, which was also a great
lesson in like sometimes you got to just
learn to spend money and enjoy what you
spend. a different thing for a different
time. Um, but that being said, you also
benefit from that customer anticipation
when you set up the payment this way.
So, there's a lot of benefits to doing
this way. And the biggest one of all,
you risk nothing. They pay before you
deliver anything. And so, you get to
have the cash before you have to risk
delivery. So, those are all different
ways you can accelerate cash flow in the
business. Um, I'll give you a Let's see
here. Do I have do I have any more notes
that I wanted to go over? Yeah, I was
going to give you guys some rules of
thumbs for like different kind of
conversion metrics. So, one of the
simple ones would be like if you're
doing thing is there's so many
variations. So, it's like if you're
closing off of meta leads for in person,
it's like you should close 10% of the
leads that that you have. So, you get
100 leads for an inerson service
business, you should close about 10%.
Um, if you're, you know, above that,
amazing. If you're below that, you
probably have some opportunity for
improvement. Um, if you're closing off
cold webinar leads, um, if you're
selling to broader markets, you're
probably looking at 2 to 3% conversion
of those leads, as in webinar opt-ins to
sales. If you are a little bit more
niched, then that can go up to 5% of
leads. Um, the craziest I've ever seen.
And like again, that's leads, not shows,
right? Or people who are there during
the offer. That's just overall like you
had 100 people opt in for webinar. All
right. Um, if you have a salesperson
that's in person, right? If you're going
to someone's home, um again, my rule of
thumb with sales people in general with
a proper sales process is 35%. I would
like them to close at least one out of
three um of the prospects that they're
getting touched with. Typically, if it's
higher than that, I will raise price. Um
and if it's below that, then uh then I
will fix the process before I even
consider lowering the price. Um web
pages, most times it's going to be
between 1 and 2%. Um in terms of
conversion rate on those pages, I'll
I'll give you a fun factoid for uh
school. So I think school right now is
at like 4%. It's really good u for
school about pages and it's because when
you have trust in a platform that starts
to increase your conversion overall. So
I'll give you a wild example on this.
Again these are rules of thumb. Um my
Amazon page for my books. So like offers
for example this is the last time I
looked. Um we convert roughly a quarter
of the traffic that hits that page. That
crazy is one out of four clicks buys.
Now, what you trade off when you have a
platform like an Amazon, right, is that
I'm not making all that money. Amazon's
basically making all the money and then
like paying me a small commission. And
so, you just have to play with the
numbers there, which is like, okay,
instead of it being uh, you know, 25%,
I'm getting two and a half%. So, I'm
getting 10x the conversion per click and
I might be getting onethird the gross
profit. Is it worth it? Yeah. Still
making three times as much money, right?
But you just have to understand the
difference between those things. I'll
leave you with a final uh rule number
nine, which is my I'm filling the holes
back up. Rule number nine. Uh anybody
remember love potion number nine? I
might be dating myself. Uh that was a
that was a movie. You can Google it.
Anyways, uh
I'll bring this up, which is this
industry averages are dumb. And so what
do I mean by that?
The amount of times I've had a
conversation where someone says, "Hey,
you know, manufacturing these these uh
you know, these are these margins are
pretty good for manufacturing." Or,
"Hey, uh, you know, our margins are this
in our industry." It's like, if the
average American is in debt, divorced
twice, overweight, and just mid as
right? Why would I want to have that be
my bar to compare myself against?
You say you have this I mean so many so
many you know business owners have this
hatred for their competition. They hate
their competition. They want to crush
their competition. And yet you want to
measure yourself by the same stick that
your competition measures themselves.
Well, it's a great way to be average,
right? Is use averages as as your
determination of whether or not you're
good. And so I would highly encourage
you to just ignore averages altogether
and play to win. And that is just
something that has that has really
served me well, which is like somebody
will I'll come into his space and we'll
say, "Well, you know, you'll learn, you
know, I don't know if you guys have seen
this clip um of Tiger Woods when he's
doing his first interview before his
first masters or something." And the
guy's like, he's like, "Well, uh, you
know, how do you feel being so young,
you know, coming on on the Masters
tour?" And he's I don't know how it gets
to it, but he's like, "I'm here to win
or I'm playing to win." And the guy's
like, "You'll learn. you know, you'll
see. And then they play it forward like
a year or two or whatever and he's there
with his jacket talking to the same guy
and the guy just has to like eat his
words. Like it's so visceral. Like the
moment is amazing. And so like that is
what I envision when I go into an
industry that I don't know anything
about. It's like that is the advantage.
I'm not going to you I'm not going to
I'm not going to operate within your
frame of reality. Like why would I
operate within the frame of beliefs that
what the average person has achieved is
what I will achieve. Why would I say
that is the appropriate outcome that I
should be shooting for? What? Because
fundamentally when you quote an average
to say this is good enough, you've
accepted that you are no longer going to
try to get better. And I just
wholeheartedly reject that. Like
like the winner of every category is not
the industry average. And I and I can
almost promise you that they don't look
at the industry average because why
would they care? Like there is only like
one rule that matters which is physics.
If it's as long as the rules of physics
allow it to exist, there's no reason
these that that we cannot get this
outcome that we desire. Period.
And so I'll get asked a question like,
do you think you can have uh margins in
a manufacturing business that are above
10%. Yes. You know how I know? I also
have a friend of mine who does complex
machinery. You know what his margins
are? Net 70%.
Net. Well, what does that mean about his
gross margins? That means they got to be
way above 70. You want to know what how
he did it? He builds machines that he
sells to big industries that automate a
huge function of different workflows.
And he will charge $400,000 and a
machine will cost him 17 grand because
he has knowhow. And so if you think
about what a business is, a business is
functionally a black box
that transforms raw materials into an
output where the value is higher than
the inputs. That's it. That's all a
business does is we have raw inputs. We
transform these inputs into something
that is more valuable at the end. That
is all a business does. And when we do
this over and over again over an entire
civilization, we take many raw inputs
and we we increase value and that is how
the entire world moves forward. And so
that being said, those are my 12 rules
of thumb uh that I've learned uh in
business. Different ratios that I use as
my guidepost, my lights, my lights, my
what's the light towers? What are those
things on the edge of oceans?
>> Lighthouse.
>> Lighthouse. Those are the lighouses that
guide my path. Um, and I hope they serve
you as much um as they have served